le centre de vaccination de l'université
fédérale de niteroi la grosse ville de
l'autre côté de la baie de rio de
janeiro vaccine en moyenne 900 personnes
par jour
tout est fluide et bien rodée ici on
administre le vaccin d'astrazeneca
fabriqués sous licence au brésil en
principe les états et les villes ont un
ordre de priorité pour la vaccination
mais ici à niteroi ont fait exception
des jeunes peuvent déjà se faire
vacciner
et comme mélissa il se félicite de
l'avoir fait
content que mon dieu on
croire que le futur
on nous dit que même des étrangers
pourraient recevoir le vaccin ce qui
montre qu'en l'absence de politique
centralisée et coordonnée ont fait un
peu ce qu'on veut alors que le brésil
manque encore cruellement de vaccins on
vient juste d'espacer les deux doses du
vaccin chronvac ce qui a rendu furieux
des gens qui se sont présentés en vain
alors rendez vous corona vaka vexin
chinois et le deuxième fabriqués sous
licence au brésil dans les laboratoires
boutantin de san paolo l'astra zenica et
fabriqué par le centre de recherche
fédéral fiocruz de rio de janeiro où
travaille la docteure margaret dans le
komo elle participe à l'élaboration des
avis scientifiques du brésil et elle
constate le manque cruel de vaccins
d'abord le brésil n'a pas négocié dans
ce que j'appellerais en timing correct
quand les essais cliniques sont été
développé dans les pays
nous avons laissé sa mauvaise stratégie
aussi incohérence à brasilia nous avons
fait des essais de phase iii au brésil
avec dix mille volontaires brésilien
mais pourtant nous n'avons pas négocié
avec ce fabricant rien pas une décision
politique
les essais ont été faits avec johnson &
johnson qui n'a pas été commandé et avec
foi et eux dont le gouvernement a
d'abord refusé 70 millions de doses en
août 2020 avant d'en commander 100
millions le sénat brésilien a lancé une
enquête parlementaire sur la gestion de
la pandémie par le gouvernement de
jaillir ball sonar aux essais quatre
ministres de la santé successifs
la pandémie est un fléau divin mais il
ya aussi des responsables dit le
rapporteur de la commission
la cpi par action commission ou
incompétence ou pas d'inspiration 1100d
y donne compétence et si c'est prouvé
ils devront rendre des comptes d'île
sénateur de la a entamé une procédure de
destitution du président jacques bolson
à eau
c'est ce que réclame déjà une partie de
la population
malgré la baisse des décès les
scientifiques sont très inquiets à cause
du variant paix est plus virulent non je
dis qu'au brésil
la situation est encore catastrophique
pourquoi parce que nous ne savons pas
encore si nous aurons par exemple une
troisième vague d' une troisième vague
en juin pas impossible
jean michel leprince radio canada rio de
janeiro